from leading roles right down to clever
cameos here are the characters who have
appeared in the most MCU movies ranked
in order from least to most appearances
Peter Parker has two titular films to
his name and has been a regular in the
Avengers lineup ever since he swung on
to the scene back in the airport battle
in Captain America Civil War
big fan spider-man for those of you
counting at home that puts the crime
stopper from Queens at five entertaining
on-screen adventures with infinity war
and endgame however depending on how
loosely you define appearance you can
tally up spider-man's total MCU
appearances at 6 where's the sick do you
ask well you have to go all the way back
to Iron Man 2 for that one for years it
was rumoured that it was none other than
kid Peter Parker who donned an Iron Man
mask and faced down the hammered road
during the stark Expo in the Iron Man
sequel well fan theories are nice and
all
Spidey actor Tom Holland himself /
confirmed the guest in an interview back
in 2017 there were few supporting
characters in the MCU boys suffer more
promising future than Sam Wilson the
airborne Avenger has faithfully served
by Steve Rogers side ever since cap
zipped past him on his morning jog in
the opening scene of Captain America the
Winter Soldier in that first appearance
the lovable veteran is instrumental in
taking down a Hydra infiltrated shield
he's eventually made a member of the
Avengers in age of Ultron soon after
that he finds himself on the wrong end
of a tussle with ant-man in the little
guys solo flick before he joins in the
divisive action of Civil War Wilson then
takes part in the all-inclusive doll
superhero romp of Avengers infinity war
and the Vengeance end game coming out of
the fray as the newly appointed freshly
anointed Captain America filling Steve
Rogers super soldier sized shoes is a
task that will keep Wilson returning to
action starting with the Falcon and the
Winter Soldier Disney Plus series happy
Hogan has always been a faithful alumnus
of the Ironman franchise and in spite of
his relatively minor role in the MCU the
four head of security managed to find
his way into a surprisingly robust six
different movies across the universe he
first appears on the scene right at the
genesis of the MCU serving as Tony
Stark's faithful bodyguard and best
friend
half proceeds to played significant
roles in all three of Starks films
before you franchise tops over to Peter
Parker's narrative with spider-man
homecoming and he knows a little more
screentime in ends game with Starks
story wrapped up it feels as if Happy's
tale is also about to come to a
well-earned end except it doesn't the
ends up making a comeback and spider-man
far from home where he shows up
repeatedly dating the superheroes and
the differing Starks inheritance and
ultimately giving Parker the pep talk he
needs what he's at his lowest are you
dating yes Loki's illustrious career
begins way back in Thor where he figures
prominently along with his brother he
takes his villainous pursuits to all new
levels when he shows up again in the
Avengers working for Thanos wielding the
mind stone stealing the tesseract and
eventually leading the Chitauri invasion
of New York from there the Prince of
Lies begins to temper his wicked side
substituting it for a mischievous
antihero vibe that he sports throughout
the following two Thor films and right
on into infinity war surprise here he
tragically meets his end at the powerful
purple hand of his past employer of
course the son of Luffy isn't quite
finished yet as he pops up in another
timeline and steals the tesseracts again
in ends game to top it all off the
sneaky fellow is set to make his
multiverse debut in his own Disney Plus
show whether he'll make it into another
movie though is an open question if
anyone has a right to beat Sal's happy
Hogan in the Tony Stark allegiance game
its Pepper Potts pepper has faithfully
stuck by Starks side through thick and
thin with the one exception being that
minor break up during civil war not
surprisingly she has hefty roles
throughout all of the Iron Man trilogy
and she takes part in every Avengers
film with the exception of age of Ultron
which was close to the break-up so we
don't blame her she also appears at the
end of spider-man homecoming bringing
her total to 7
well most of her appearances have
revolved around her role as Tony songs
for Montek interest as well as her
duties as head of Stark Industries it
was fun to see buffs finally done that
rescue armor in Avengers end game and
join in on the action with stark out of
the picture for the foreseeable future
it's unlikely that parts will add to her
tally
especially since Gwyneth Paltrow
confirmed
and game would be her last MCU
appearance sergeant James Buchanan
Barnes
better known to fans of the MCU as Bucky
has had a major supporting role
throughout both Steve Rogers and the
Avengers storylines
in fact when you boil it down Bucky
could be considered one of the major
catalyst that led to the entire Infinity
Saga playing out the way it did I'm with
you to the end of the line pal Barnes
first appears in caps first film where
he plays the part of the loyal friend
before apparently falling to his death
he reappears in the sequel film this
time as a brainwashed Winter Soldier
from there Bucky's involvement goes from
interesting to essential in the
post-credits scene for ant-man the stage
is set for his involvement on the
catastrophic events of civil war he also
makes a brief appearance in the
post-credits scene for black panther
serving as an early premonition for
infinity war a film that he also
participates in along with its sequel
while burns has never been more than a
supporting character and more than one
of his appearances were in small roles
or end credits scenes he still managed
to maintain a dynamic presence
throughout his MCU career Colonel James
Rhodes also known as war machine has
been with the MCU since its inception
showing up a total of eight times since
his early days even if he does so was
one of the few characters to be played
by more than one actor Rhodey books time
in all three Iron Man films Captain
America Civil War and the mid-credits
scene in Captain Marvel while he failed
to make the original Avengers roster he
does eventually join the squad
consequentially showing up in the second
third and fourth Avengers films from his
early days spent reining in and out of
control Tony Stark to his later career
spent helping to save the universe war
machine has shown himself to be a loyal
friend a fearsome warrior and a
character with incredible resilience in
the face of hardship and difficulty Hulk
and Bruce Banner have grudgingly shared
the silver screen for over a decade
until they finally made up and chose to
collaborate as Professor Hulk in
Avengers end game if you count the two
characters as one you end up with a
character who showed up in the MCU a
whopping eight different times these
appearances are as different as the two
personalities varying from their moody
solo film to hoax glory days as a Grand
Master's champion in Thor Ragnarok kind
of like fire
all collected real fire but like raging
fire
do I like smoldering fire as Avengers
alumni the pair faithfully show up
during all four Avengers films banner
also drops in for a pair of post credits
scenes in both Iron Man 3 and Captain
Marvel with such a checkered history it
was a relief to see professor Hulk
finally bring some stability to the big
green guys story although with the rage
brought down to a low simmer it begs the
question of if and how the pair will
ever find their way back into anything
beyond the Disney Plus series from its
early period of self-discovery to his
later involvement in Asgardian politics
and his size to the Avengers
Thor's managed to rack up eight
different MCU appearances that doesn't
even include a for solo film already in
the pipeline and the rumored guest
appearance in guardians 3 a possibility
three of his eight appearances come via
his own trilogy
he's also participated in all four
Avengers films and even has a quick
cameo in Doctor Strange the character
has gone through an incredible amount of
refining over the years his own
franchise atrophied heading into the
second film only to be revitalized in
the third installments the about-face
and the character's narrative gave Thor
a new MCU life and allowed him to bring
a new dimension to the Avengers
storyline as well with so much already
in the rearview mirror it's impressive
that Thor's MTU Korea still seems to
have so much more to give Black Widow
first appears way back in Iron Man 2
well her apparent innocence very quickly
gives way to her superhero skill set
from there she bounces over to the
Captain America franchise which he
helped Steve Rogers and Falcon topple
the Hydra infiltrated shield and takes
part in a civil war she also sneaks in a
quick end credit appearance in Captain
Marvel the other half of her on-screen
moments come via the court set of
Avengers films bringing the number to
eighth are you kidding I'm working I'm
in the middle of an interrogation this
[ __ ] is giving me everything out of
everyone on this list without a film to
their name NASA resume is the most
impressive and unfortunately the whole
without a film to their name bit will be
remedied in the not-too-distant future
when our first solo film officially
opens a phase for fun only a handful of
characters can claim to have appeared in
the MCU ten times or more three to be
precise brought alive through Robert
Junius all-encompassing performance Tony
Stark faithfully Shepherds the entire
first three phases of the MCU from start
to finish along with his own trilogy and
half the appearances in all four
Avengers films stark plays a pivotal
role than both Captain America Civil War
and spider-man homecoming he also shows
up in a short end credits scene in the
Incredible Hulk
bringing his counts up to a robust 10
different appearances stark plays a
crucial role in setting up the MCU
assembling the Avengers and finally
saving the universe itself from Thanos
as iron grip and while the chances of
his appearing again should be pretty low
given this you know the whole snap
thingie at the end of endgame there are
reports of Tony popping back up in the
standalone Black Widow movie so it looks
like Robert Downey jr. isn't quite done
with the MCU yet Steve Rogers has been
an MCU faithful right from the early
days of phase 1 steadily embodying the
heart and soul of the universe
throughout all of its many twists and
turns along with Thor and Stark cap is
one of the few characters that can claim
to have an entire solo trilogy and an
appearance in all four Avengers films on
some of that Rogers has popped into
end-credit scenes in Captain Marvel and
ant-man and he can be seen rattling off
PSA messages throughout spider-man
homecoming so your bodies change I know
this puts him in a dead tie with stuck
but there's a tiebreaker
however fragile it might be cap also
indirectly makes an appearance in Thor
the dark world via one of Loki's
illusions firmly in first place we have
Nick Fury super spy director of shield
and the true assembler of the Avengers
fury manages to beat Sal to everyone
when it comes to a sheer number of MCU
appearances and the wonder to the 100%
red-blooded earth man has had his hand
practically in every earthbound MCU tale
to date he's there to recruit Iron Man
Hulk and Captain America right from the
get-go he helps bring the Avengers
together in order to stave off disaster
on multiple occasions hecka the guy is
busy hobnobbing with Carol Danvers
decades before the current MCU ever gets
into motion and he's immediately back in
action recruiting Peter Parker one sends
game wraps up well sort of at the very
least he's enjoying the little space
vacation during spider-man far from home
even with the Infinity saga in the
rearview mirror fury is still actively
at the helm prepping for the future and
making sure that he shows up wherever
he's needed
which means he likely won't lose his
place at the top of this list any time
soon check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
but your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the bail so you don't miss a single one
[Music]